Prof: What I'm planning
to do today is to spend a half
an hour or less just telling you
a little bit about what a new
theory might be,
what I call the Leverage Cycle,
and then spend the rest of the
time maybe answering questions
about the course that you might
have.
I could, if you wanted to,
devote the whole time to what
the new theory is,
but why don't I at least pause
after a half an hour and see if
you have questions?
So what is the thing that's
been missing from the entire
course and has been missing from
economic theory,
I think, almost entirely for
all these years,
and certainly missing from all
the textbooks that you might
have looked at during the course
of the semester,
and you remember there was a
list of 20 books or something
you could have read,
and that's the idea of
collateral.
It's the idea that in order to
guarantee that you're going to
keep your promise you have to
put up collateral,
and people just don't trust in
everyone else keeping their
promise,
they want collateral.
So if you put that into the
model what sorts of things might
be different?
So I want to just work out an
example so you can see how they
might change.
I want to talk about an example
that's going to illustrate what
happened in our crisis.
And I guess that it's a little
interesting that I wrote this
and I presented this in 2000 at
the World Congress,
and it got published in 2003,
so this was long before the
crisis.
Now, as I said,
there had been other smaller
crises before in 1998,
maybe '94, maybe '87,
certainly '98,
and of course I was thinking
about these previous crises when
I built this model,
but not many other people
thought much of those other
crises.
And as it happens,
this last one that we're still
at the bottom of,
or a little past the bottom of,
I think is very similar to the
ones we had before,
but just much bigger.
So here's my simple version of
it.
I'm going to give two models,
a very simple one with two
periods and a slightly more
complicated one with three
periods,
and of course all the
interesting things happen in the
three-period case,
but just to make it simple to
understand I'm starting with the
simpler one.
So suppose that there's a
security which I'm going to call
Y that everybody holds.
Why is there no chalk?
Gosh, I taught the class in
here, I just finished lecturing
in here with a whole box,
oh here it is,
a whole box of chalk.
So suppose that there's a
security Y that I'm going to
think of as a mortgage security,
or you could think of it as a
house,
or you could think of it as an
oil well that has uncertain
output in the next period.
And then there's going to be
something like gold that I'll
call X.
So this might be like gold,
and this might be like a
mortgage security,
or like an oil well,
or you might think of it as a
house,
but I'll think of a mortgage
security,
an oil well.
It's something that pays an
uncertain outcome in the future,
and this is something that's
very stable and you know exactly
you've got gold this period,
if you just save it you'll have
the same gold next period.
So now people are going to
differ according to how
optimistic or pessimistic they
are.
That's my idea of,
not everybody's the same.
So I imagine that there are two
possibilities next period.
Either the Y,
the oil well,
could produce--it's a gold-well
really.
It could produce 2 pieces of
gold, I mean,
1 piece of gold,
or it could produce .2,20
percent of a piece of gold.
So everybody begins with 1 oil
well,
1 mortgage security and 1 piece
of gold,
so they can consume the gold or
they can make it a filling for
their teeth,
or they can wait next period
and then they'd have it in
either state next period because
it's perfectly durable,
or they could use the gold to
buy more oil wells,
each of which might pay off 1
or .2.
So that's it.
Now people care about the
consumption of gold.
The only reason to get the oil
well,
as Fisher, as we've assumed all
through the class,
the only reason to get the oil
well is that it might produce
gold for you next period,
gushing oil, money, gold.
It might gush some gold for you
next period.
So people care about
consumption, how much gold they
eat here,
times the probability that
they're going to be up here,
times how much they eat here,
plus the probability that
they're going to come down here,
times how much they eat here.
In other words they are risk
neutral with no discounting and
they just multiply consumption
here and here by the
probabilities and add the
consumptions,
and then add it to the
consumption here.
Everybody's got the same
utility, but with one
difference.
H is the probability agent H
attaches to going up.
So I think of these people as a
continuum of buyers now.
Instead of 2 buyers like we've
always had,
or 3 buyers,
or even 1 buyer ,
I've got a continuum and
they're different because some
are more optimistic than others.
Now, this is stuff that we
haven't really paid much
attention to before.
So these optimists are the
people who have H very close to
1,
and lots of other people have
Hs in the middle,
and there are some people who
think H is 0.
That's the way they differ.
So of course the very most
optimistic person thinks the oil
well is worth 1 piece of gold.
He doesn't discount,
and he thinks he's going to get
1 for sure, so he'd be willing
to pay 1 for it here.
The most pessimistic person
thinks the oil well is only
worth .2.
And let's say she'd only be
willing to pay .2 for it here.
So what's the price of oil
wells going to be?
Well, if we just had our usual
model,
a one period model,
we would see that the people
with the high H would sell their
gold to buy more oil wells
because they thought it would be
valuable,
and the people with the low Hs,
thinking the oil wells weren't
worth much,
would sell them to the high H
people to get more gold in the
present.
That's basically what would
happen.
And you'd get some dividing
line where the people above A
would be buying oil wells,
spending all their money.
And the people below A would be
selling oil wells and getting
more money.
So, for example,
if A was .69,
which is what it's going to
turn out to be,
Mr. A, what does he think the
value of an oil well is?
He thinks it's .69 times 1 .31
times .2 which is .06,
so .69 .06 is .75.
So Mr.
69 thinks the oil well's worth
about 75.
Everyone above him thinks it's
worth more than 75,
so if the price were .75
everyone above would want to buy
and everyone below would say
it's not worth .75 so I'll sell
it,
and since they're risk neutral
their valuation is independent
of how much of it they have.
So these people below would
want to sell everything,
and these people above would
want to buy everything.
So that's nothing different
from what we've done from the
very beginning except that maybe
the one difference is people
would go to the extreme.
These guys would spend all
their money buying oil wells
because every time they bought
an oil well at a price of .75
this guy,
for example,
was sure it's worth 1.
The more he buys the better he
is.
So he'd spend all his money in
oil wells and these guys would
sell all their oil wells,
but other than that it's very
similar to what we've done.
So what's the difference going
to be?
The difference is just one
thing.
Where do I divide this dividing
line A?
Well, can these guys up here
afford to buy all these oil
wells?
Well, the answer is,
so far, it doesn't look like
that's possible,
because if the dividing line is
way up here these guys up here
don't have enough money to buy
all the oil wells down here.
After all, they only have 1
piece of gold apiece and if the
oil well costs 75 they can each
buy 1 and 1 third.
If you multiply that by 1 and 1
third you're never going to buy
all these oil wells down here.
So this seems like it's too
high for A to be.
So the new twist is,
maybe the guys up here who want
the oil wells,
who are so sure they're going
to do well,
maybe they can borrow money to
buy the oil wells.
So they can make a promise to
pay money in the future,
maybe .5 and .5 in the future,
say,
and then sell those promises,
borrow money in other words,
promising in the future,
and then use that money to buy
more oil wells.
So that's what people do in the
market.
Any hedge fund,
the three definitions of a
hedge fund,
the three defining
characteristics of a hedge fund,
I think I might have said once,
are,
a) that they hedge,
so unlike other money managers
they're always trying to hedge.
And we talked about what
hedging is.
And many, many more managers
are doing that than ever before.
It's different from 50 percent
of the people,
but not from,
you know, the hedge funds are 5
percent and the other 45 percent
are also hedging,
so that's not so different.
The second thing they do is
they borrow money to make their
investments.
A lot of these other managers
aren't allowed to borrow.
They may not be allowed to
hedge either.
Those are called long only
managers.
They can't hedge.
Some of them can't borrow.
Hedge funds hedge and borrow,
and then hedge funds charge
high fees.
That's the third defining
characteristic.
But anyway, so they borrow.
And in the economy,
I told you last time,
a huge number of people
borrowed a huge amount of money.
So borrowing is obviously very
important.
So how much are they going to
be able to borrow?
I mean, this guy,
number one, he'd like to borrow
as much as he could.
Every time he borrows money
he's sure that he's going to be
up here,
so every time he borrows 1
dollar he gets to make an
investment that he's sure is
going to be a great investment,
and he's planning on paying
everything back because he's
sure he's going to go here,
so he's going to be incredibly
rich.
So he's going to pay back what
he borrows, but he's going to
get such a profit he's going to
make a fortune.
So if people could borrow
however much they wanted to,
and promise to payback,
this guy would borrow
everything,
Mr.
1, I mean, would borrow
everything and imagine he was
going to get up here for sure,
and imagine he was going to
keep his promise for sure,
and he bid the price up almost
to 1.
But now, who's going to lend to
him and how much will they
actually lend to him?
Well, in our old world we
didn't worry about who was going
to lend.
Everybody assumed they were
going to get paid back,
but in reality people don't
assume they're going to get paid
back.
The lenders are going to say to
themselves,
"Wait a minute,
if this guy promises us to pay
us,
say, .5 and .5 maybe he'll be
very rich over here and he'll be
able to pay us back,
but I'm not sure he's going to
be so rich here.
I don't even know what he has.
How do I know what the borrower
is going to actually have in
these states?"
I don't want to look into his
personal bank account and find
out everything about him.
That's the way,
banks who lend sometimes do
that and they go to a lot of
effort to check how reliable a
borrower you are,
but people in general,
most of the lenders,
you don't want to do that.
That was the idea of
securitization.
We don't have to have so much
careful looking into the
personal finances of everybody.
Much simpler is to use the
asset Y as collateral.
So if Y is collateral,
what does that mean?
When you lend 1 dollar to a
borrower the borrower just
doesn't borrow the dollar
promising to pay something back
in the future.
The borrower says,
"if I don't pay you back
you can take the asset."
So the question is,
for each unit of the asset Y,
how much can you borrow when
you have the asset as
collateral?
That's the question of leverage.
So if you take the value of Y
divided by the cash down--so
let's do two numbers.
So the borrowed,
dollars borrowed using Y as
collateral, that divided by the
value of Y, that's what we call
the loan to value,
LTV, loan to value.
Another way of saying that is
the borrowed,
if you take Y,
dollar Y minus dollars
borrowed, that--let's write it
in the denominator.
Dollar Y minus dollars
borrowed, and here you put value
of Y, so just dollar Y,
in other words.
The dollar of Y minus the
dollar borrowed,
that's the cash you had to put
down.
So that's the dollar of Y
divided by the cash down.
That's what's called leverage.
So, and it's obviously the same
thing as loan to value because
you just sort of invert the
number and do a subtraction,
you get leverage.
So if you knew the loan to
value you'd know the leverage
and vice versa.
They're the same thing.
So what should the loan to
value be?
And so as I said,
historically what's happened
over the last ten years for
housing is you had to put 14
percent down.
The leverage was 7 for buying
houses,
non-agency houses,
non-prime houses,
starting in 2000,
and then it went to 33 or 35 to
1 because you put down less than
3 percent in 2006.
So this leverage shot up and
then it suddenly collapsed.
You had to put 25 percent down,
so leverage fell to 4.
So that, I'm going to explain,
has a big effect on the price
of housing and the price of
mortgage securities.
So what should leverage be?
How can supply and demand
determine what leverage is?
So it seems like you've got to
clear all these markets.
You've got to figure out how
does the Y market clear,
how does the gold market clear,
and then on top of that you
have to figure out leverage.
It seems like it's a lot of
complicated things to figure
out.
And I think economists just
thought,
"Oh, there's so much going
on,
and people are really generally
keeping their promises anyway,
let's ignore the fact that you
have to have all this
collateral."
Well, I think that collateral
is the heart of the problem in
finance.
So how would it work in this
model?
So are you with me about where
we're going?
So you have to conceptually
figure out how to think about
the problem.
In other words,
conceptually,
the question is,
how can supply equals demand,
which sounds like one equation,
how can that determine the
interest rate,
supply equals demand for loan,
how can that determine the
interest rate and the leverage?
It seems like you have one
equation and how can you
determine two things with one
equation?
Well, the answer is that you
can do it, but first we need a
conceptual framework to think
about it.
So it seems like a
contradiction almost,
a mathematical contradiction,
so it must be that the problem
is ill posed,
and so I claim it is.
So what you really should be
thinking is that there's not
just one interest rate,
and one leverage,
you should be thinking that
there's the promise and then
there's the collateral and those
things taken together define the
contract.
So let's say the promise is .2,
.2, and the collateral is 1
unit of Y, .2 of X,
.2 of X.
So you're promising 2 units
[correction: 0.2 units]
of gold in the future and
you've got 1 unit of Y as your
collateral.
So that implies a delivery of
.2 and .2.
Why is that?
Because in the good state at
the top the collateral is worth
1,
so if you've made the promise
and the lender can seize your
collateral if you don't pay,
you're going to either pay .2
or he's going to seize the
collateral,
and so you're going to pay .2.
Maybe you'll sell some of the
collateral to pay .2.
And if the promise is .2 down
here,
the same thing,
either he's going to seize the
collateral,
the lender will seize the
collateral or you'll sell it and
keep your promise.
In either case it'll deliver .2
and .2, and it's going to sell
for some price.
And the price is actually going
to be 1, so the interest rate
effectively is 0.
Now, why is that?
Well, because at time 0 over
here no one discounts the
future.
Gold at the beginning is worth
exact--
to everybody--a unit of gold at
the beginning is the same as a
unit of gold at the end in both
states because everyone's
probabilities add up to 1.
H (1 - H) is 1.
So you might as well consume at
the beginning or for sure at the
end.
So since there's a lot of gold
sloshing around here there are
always lenders willing to lend
at a 0 percent interest and
they're getting their money back
for sure.
So it'll turn out that the
interest rate on this kind of
loan,
which is riskless,
is going to be 0,
because no one's discounting
and they're getting their money
for sure.
But what if you promised .3 and
.3 with 1 unit of Y as
collateral?
Then what would the delivery be
in that case?
Well, the delivery wouldn't be
(.3, .3) because the only thing
protecting the promise is the
collateral.
The delivery would be .3 and
.2, right?
Because in the up state your
collateral is worth 1,
and so you would be forced to
pay the .3,
in the down state you would do
what a lot of homeowners are
doing now and say,
"Okay, I owe you so much
money.
My loan to value is 150 percent.
The value of my house has gone
down to 2 thirds.
The loan is 150 percent of the
value of my house.
I'd be crazy to pay you 150
percent.
Effectively I don't own my
house.
I owe so much more on my house
than the house is worth.
I can't give it to my children.
I can't do anything with the
house anyway.
Why should I just pay such a
huge amount of money?
I might as well just give up
the house."
They walk away from the house
and the lender gets .2.
So (.3, .2) would be the
delivery, and of course if it
was .4 and .4 it would also be
.4 and .2.
Now, if you made this promise
of .3 and .3 you'd be delivering
something more than .2 at the
top.
So the price,
of course, would be more than
.3 [correction:
more than 0.2].
So the price might be--price of
the .3 promise will turn out to
be something like .261,
say.
It might be .261.
Let's just say .261.
So effectively you're borrowing
.261, you're delivering .3.
This is the .3.
This is up here,
pi_.3 = .261,
the sub .3.
So effectively your interest
rate is, in the state when you
can pay back at the top,
your interest rate is .3 over
.261.
It's like 14 percent or 15
percent actually.
It's 15 percent,
so .3 over .261 is 1.15,
so this over here means 15
percent interest.
So you've effectively,
because they know you're going
to default in one of the states
you have to pay much more than
you borrowed in the good state.
So effectively you're promising
a 15 percent interest.
You're promising it in all the
states.
You're only delivering a
portion of what you promise in
the bad state.
All right, so what's my point?
My point is that the apparent
contradiction,
supply equals demand
determining both interest and
leverage,
is no contradiction at all
because actually we've got many
supply equals demand equations.
There are many different loans
depending on the ratio of the
collateral to the promise.
There are many different loans
and each of them sells for a
different price.
So we've got many different
things we're determining,
many interest rates,
but one supply equals demand
equation for each one.
So every supply equals demand
equation produces one price.
There's no contradiction.
However, that still leaves us
with the question,
which of these many contracts
are going to be traded?
Can we say that the economy as
a whole has a single leverage?
And there the surprise is,
and this is the end of the
first part of the model,
the surprise is,
yes we can.
Only this one is going to get
traded.
So everybody in the economy,
no matter how optimistic you
are or how pessimistic you are,
even though you have the
available chance to make a
bigger promise,
and of course having to promise
a bigger interest rate,
sorry, there's the interest
rate.
Even though everyone has
available that opportunity,
they won't avail themselves of
that.
Everybody will trade on this
promise.
So how could that be?
And by the way,
before we answer that question
let's just see that if everyone
used this promise that in fact
the price we talked about before
would prevail.
So why is this .69--that A
should be a little lower,
it doesn't look like .69.
It looks a little too high,
but anyway it's supposed to be
69 percent of the way up.
Why is that the right price?
Well, how much could these guys
buy?
Well, the top 31 percent,
what can they do?
They've got .31 cigarettes.
So I'll write it over here.
They've got .31 cigarettes
between them.
The top 31 percent are the
buyers, right?
So we've got 31 percent here
and 69 percent of the people
down here, and here's A = .69.
So these guys have .31
cigarettes between them.
Now, if they promise,
every time they buy an oil well
they promise .2 units,
every one of them,
they're going to buy all the
oil wells in the whole economy.
So however many people there
are here, let's call it mass of
1, maybe it's a million people,
mass of 1, they're going to
borrow .2.
So this is their own gold and
this is borrowed gold.
Student: When you say
cigarettes you're talking about
gold?
Prof: Did I say
cigarettes?
Yes, I meant, yeah.
It's another example of gold.
I meant gold.
So you could think of gold,
consume it now or consume it
later.
Cigarettes you can consume now
or consume later.
I have all these things in my
head of what I could have
interpreted, so yeah,
I mean gold.
So you can consume the gold,
thank you, the gold now or the
gold later, so each of these
guys owns 1 unit of gold.
So 31 percent of the population
has 1 unit of gold.
So you've got .31 total units
of gold.
They end up buying all the oil
wells, and so how much can they
borrow on all the oil wells
using as collateral?
So the oil wells they started
with, they borrow using those as
collateral, and the oil wells
that they buy they also use as
collateral.
So they've got all the oil
wells.
They're making the (.2,
.2) promise but it has a price
of 1.
There's no interest.
The interest rate is 0,
so they're borrowing .2.
So the total amount of gold
that they have at their disposal
is .31 .2, and how many oil
wells do they have to buy,
69 percent of the oil wells,
.69.
And if you take 31 and 20
that's 51 over 69,
which is about .75,
which is exactly what I said
the price is that's going to
make this guy,
Mr.
69, exactly indifferent to
buying or selling.
So all the people up here are
going to say,
"At the price of .75 it
really is a good deal,
I want to buy and borrow as
much as I can."
People down here are all going
to want to sell.
The people up here with the
money they started with plus
what they can borrow are going
to be able to indeed buy all
these oil wells at a price of
.75.
That's what we just found and
that's why that's the
equilibrium.
Did that go too fast,
or almost too fast?
Yeah, question?
Student: I was just
wondering, for the price of the
.2 pounds, why is that 1?
Prof: Because you're
going to get the money for sure.
So how much money is being
lent, basically .2.
So there are a huge number of
guys down here.
Their total amount of gold is
.69, right?
There's one unit of gold in the
whole economy.
They own 69 percent of the gold
and they're only lending in
total .2.
So there's lots of extra gold
that they have that they're not
lending.
They don't care whether they
get gold now or gold later
because there's no discounting
and they're getting the money
back for sure.
So competition between these
lenders is going to drive the
interest rate all the way to 0.
If the interest rate were
positive they'd all want to rush
in and lend because then they're
going to get more gold out at
the end than they had at the
beginning and there's not
discounting.
So the competition among
lenders will drive the interest
rate down to 0,
and they're guaranteed to get
paid back because the
collateral's big enough.
You had a question?
Student: I'm still
confused.
For the first state if you only
promise to pay .2 in the future,
so shouldn't the price be .2
right now?
Prof: Oh,
and I said the price is 1.
Yes.
The price per unit is .2.
Yeah, that's horrible.
Thank you.
The price is .2, exactly.
The price is .2 for the promise
of (.2, .2).
It's price of 1 per unit
promise.
The price is .2, exactly.
Gosh, what a terrible mistake.
Thank you very much.
It's .2, exactly,
and that's why these guys
they're able to--
they're promising .2 and the
price per unit promise,
so this price was,
yeah, its price is .2.
So per unit promise their price
is 1, in other words.
So they're promising .2 and per
unit promise the price is 1,
so the price of the whole
promise is .2,
exactly, so it's just that,
so that was--
so the price is .2.
Using the whole of the
economy's worth of oil wells as
collateral you can promise 20
percent of all the gold and then
you're going to get--
you'll be able to borrow doing
that the same amount,
20 percent of all the gold,
because the interest rate's 0.
Yes?
So that's why this total amount
of gold that they can get their
hands on,
some people call it liquidity,
all the stuff they can get
their hands on,
capital, they take all that and
they buy all the oil wells they
can.
This is how many are being
sold, and that's therefore what
the price is.
The ratio of 51 to 69 is almost
exactly .75, so I'm rounding off
a little bit.
And that's why Mr. A of .69
is indifferent at this price to
buying or selling.
The guys above him all want to
buy.
This is how much money they can
get their hands on and therefore
what they can spend.
All these guys want to sell.
That's what they're selling.
That's why this justifies the
price, and these guys are the
ones lending to these guys.
The pessimists have nothing to
do but lend because they don't
want to buy the asset.
Does this make sense?
I'm just going to repeat the
same thing with a three period
model where it gets more
exciting, but the logic of this
is critical.
So is everyone with me?
Now, there's one thing I left
out in this one period model,
two period model,
which is what about the (.3,
.3) promise?
The optimist, H equals 1.
Take that guy.
He says to himself,
"I can't lose.
Why should I be satisfied with
only promising (.2,
.2)?
Why don't I make a bigger
promise like (.3,
.3).
With my bigger promise I get
more money today,
and with that extra money today
I can use it and buy an oil
well,
and I'm going to make a profit
of 33 percent.
My .75 is going to turn into 1
for sure, so why isn't that just
a brilliant thing for me to do?
Why should I be satisfied?
The more oil wells I get my
hands on the better I seem to
do."
So why is he not making the
(.3, .3) promise?
So it sounds like he ought to,
but if you think about it one
more minute you'll realize that
he shouldn't.
And why is that,
because he could promise (.2,
.2).
So if he makes the (.3,
.3) promise of course he has to
give up the (.2,
.2) promise because the oil
well he used as collateral for
the (.3,
.3) promise he no longer has
available for the (.2,
.2) promise.
So the question isn't,
should he do a (.3,
.3) promise.
Well, if that was the only
thing he could do of course he
would do that,
so of course it looks
profitable, but he's already got
a great profit opportunity.
The question is,
is it a better profit
opportunity and the answer is
no.
Why is that?
Because he is still delivering
.2 down here when he makes the
(.3,
.3) promise,
but when he makes the (.3,
.3) promise he delivers more at
the top,
namely .3, but that's the state
he's sure is going to happen.
So compared to the (.2,
.2) promise he's giving away
more money just in the state
that he thinks is going to
occur.
That's very expensive for him.
That's a horrible thing for him
to have to do.
And who's lending him the money?
It's the guy down here,
and the guy down here,
that's the pessimist.
He doesn't think that top
state's going to occur so he's
only willing to pay extra money
at the beginning--
he's not willing to pay very
much extra money at the
beginning because he's going to
get stuff in a state he doesn't
think is going to happen.
So anyway, I don't have time
work it all out,
but if you think it through
you'll realize that nobody wants
to do this trade,
because the guys at the top who
seem to have the greatest
advantage in borrowing more,
when they borrow more in this
way where they're defaulting,
they're actually paying more
only in the state that they
think is going to occur and the
people doing the lending are
getting money only in the state
they think won't occur.
So both of them think it's a
worse arrangement than the
original (.2,
.2) arrangement,
and so even though there's a
price and it's available to be
traded nobody will want to trade
it.
So the market does indeed pick
out a single leverage,
and what is the leverage?
The leverage as we calculated
from this number is the price of
the asset,
which is .75 divided by the
cash down which is .55,
because you can borrow .2,
and that's 1.4 or something.
I don't know exactly,
but let's say 1.38 leverage,
1.35 is the leverage.
So it's not that high,
the leverage.
And the principle is,
that we just discovered when
you have this kind of
heterogeneity,
different kinds of
heterogeneity produce different
amount of leverage,
and I'm not going to be able to
talk about that,
but with this kind of leverage
the promise will always be the
maximum for which there is no
default.
That's how much borrowing is
going to happen,
and the market's going to
allow.
So in what market do we always
see that happening?
In the Repo market,
it's a one day market
overnight.
You put up a security as
collateral, and you can borrow
money on it, and there's almost
never any default on those
markets.
Even in the tremendous crisis
we just had almost zero defaults
in the Repo markets.
Mortgage markets there were
defaults,
but there the heterogeneity
isn't just how optimistic you
are,
it's whether you like to live
in the house or not,
so it's a different case which
I won't have time to cover.
So this is part one.
We're just going to say the
same thing in part two.
I'm going slower than I
thought, but anyway,
the last model is going to be
part two.
So are there any questions
about that?
Did this first part...
Yeah?
Student: Maybe this is
sort of a silly question,
but...
Prof: I'm sure it's not.
Student: Are there some
lenders sort of in the middle
like more optimistic pessimists
who think the upstate is more
likely to occur so maybe they're
willing to lend more money?
Prof: There are.
There are a whole continuum of
people between 0 and 1,
so the guys in the middle they
really don't have any choice
here.
You see in the next model
there's going to be a
difference, but now you really
don't have any choice.
If you're above A you should
buy to the maximum.
If you're below A you should
sell everything,
and you don't care if you lend
or not because you're definitely
going to get paid back.
So they're all willing to lend.
So let's now go to the next
model.
So that was a great question.
So far we only get two
categories of people,
buyers-borrowers,
sellers-lenders,
so we're going to move beyond
that in the next example.
Any questions about this one?
So we get equilibrium leverage
and leverage has a tremendous
effect on the price.
Why does it affect the price,
because the fact that these
guys were able to borrow so much
money is what made the price so
high.
If they couldn't borrow that
would wipe out this .2.
They couldn't have borrowed
that, so they would have only
had this much to spend,
so the price would have had to
be much lower.
And of course these guys
wouldn't have been able to
afford all of this.
So as the price gets much lower
more people would want to buy
and you would have the marginal
buyer down here,
and there'd be a much lower
price.
So this borrowing is what
jacked up the price.
Leverage means high prices.
It seems like the most obvious
thing in the world and
commonsensical thing in the
world, but remember it never got
mentioned in this course,
right?
It never gets mentioned in any
textbook.
The price is supposed to be the
fundamental value,
the present value of all the
dividends,
or the expected present value
of all the dividends,
meaning minus the covariance or
something.
Where was leverage in that
formula?
It didn't happen because we
didn't have the idea.
We assumed that everyone could
borrow as much as they wanted
to, but here we see that they
can't borrow as much as they
want to.
They're limited in how much
they can borrow,
and because they're limited
it's going to turn out,
if you make the limit less
severe they're going to borrow
more and the price is going to
be higher.
So you ignore leverage by
saying people can always borrow
whatever they want to,
then it never gets mentioned,
but it's the heart of the
matter,
I think, at least in a crisis.
So let's just do one more
version of the model,
which is this same thing,
but now with 1 extra period.
So what's the extra period
going to do?
The extra period is,
we've got instead of two
periods we have three periods.
So what's going to happen is
the .2 only happens with two
pieces of bad news.
You have to go down twice to
get .2.
Otherwise Y pays off 1.
And everyone's going to begin
at the beginning there with 1
unit of Y and 1 unit of gold
just as before,
and they could consume in the
middle,
or they could consume in the
end, but they have no more
endowments.
All their endowments are right
at the beginning,
1 unit of Y and 1 unit of gold.
There's no discounting.
They just care about the
expected consumption.
The difference is now it takes
two periods to see the
realization, so two pieces of
bad news.
Now, why is that interesting,
two pieces of bad news?
Well, when I was in the crisis
both in '98 when I thought about
this model,
created this model,
but also recently,
is people start to realize
things are going wrong.
So if something goes wrong and
now everyone says,
"Well, things are still
okay now, but I realize we're
closer."
It takes a lot of things to go
wrong for things to collapse,
but each time one of them goes
wrong you're a little closer to
the collapse.
So I make the assumption that
agents are all identical except
agent H--
high H means you think you're
going to get up moves,
but there are two moves,
at the beginning and also in
the second period.
So if you're an optimist about
the first up move you're also
going to be an optimist about
the second up move.
Now, let's suppose your H
equals .87, say,
just to pick a number,
which it's going to turn out to
be a pivotal guy.
Mr.
87 at the beginning,
the chances of going down are
13 percent for him,
then 13 percent more,
so the chance of getting a
disaster,
he thinks, is 13 percent
squared, 1.69 percent,
under 2 percent.
So he thinks the value of the
asset is over 98,
under 2 percent here the rest
of the 98 must be over there
somewhere,
so obviously his valuation is
over 98.
Now, once he gets down to here
he realizes the chances have
gone from 1.69 percent to 13
percent.
So his valuation is going to be
a little bit more than 87,
because it's going to be 87
percent of that and 13 percent
of that,
so it's 87 plus a little bit.
So he's going to go down from
98 something,
to 87 something.
So of course when the first
down state happens everybody
gets more pessimistic including
Mr.
87.
He now thinks that the asset
value maybe went from 98 to 87,
which is an 11 point drop,
and everybody's going to have a
drop.
He went from 98 plus to 87 plus
a little bit.
So it's an 11 point drop is
what he thinks happened.
So you can see this is bad news.
When it takes two things to go
wrong the first piece of bad
news people are going to take it
as bad news,
but the interesting thing that
happens is that actually they
get more uncertain.
Things go up you get 1 for sure.
Now you've learned something.
There's no uncertainty.
Here the move down created more
uncertainty than you had before,
and not only that,
more disagreement.
I mean, Mr.
.9 and Mr.
.8, neither of them thought
there was much chance of getting
down to here.
.9 thought 1 percent squared,
that's negligible.
.8 thought 2 percent squared;
that's .004.
The difference between
negligible an .004 is still
negligible,
practically,
so they hardly disagree here,
but once you get down to here
they're both starting to get
more worried and they're
actually differing a little bit
more than they did before.
So that's what I think happens
in these crises.
You go from everyone knowing if
25 things in a row go wrong
we're in trouble,
but nobody's really thinking,
except the guys at the very
bottom,
that all of this stuff can go
wrong.
But once each thing goes wrong
now everyone gets more and more
worried and there's more
separation between what people
think.
So that's just description of
the model.
So what's going to happen is
the question.
So we're almost at the end here
because we don't have to do much
more calculations.
So what will the prices be at
the beginning and down here,
and what will the leverage be
at the beginning and down here?
Well, remember our principle
that the leverage will always be
worked out in this case of
heterogeneous beliefs so that
people can promise--
so there will be no default.
The maximum promise is the most
you can make without any chance
of default.
So you can see that--I'll tell
you what the prices are.
They're going to be that.
So if you made a two period
loan, a long loan,
a lot can go wrong over a long
loan.
You can get all the way down to
.2, so you're not going to be
able to borrow very much if you
make a two period loan.
If you make a one period loan,
in a day not much can go wrong.
That's why these Repo markets
are so short.
In one day practically nothing
can go wrong,
well here something does go
wrong, but you can fall to .69.
It's a lot better than .2.
So you could borrow at the
beginning .69.
That'll be the equilibrium
promise at the beginning,
will be .69 with no interest.
The equilibrium promise here
will be .2 with no interest.
The equilibrium promise there
will be 1 with no interest.
So this turns out to be the
equilibrium.
Why?
Notice how shocking it is.
Nobody thinks the price drop
from 95 to 69 is justified.
That's a huge 26 percent drop.
Mr.
87, he thought the price should
go from 98 to 87.
That's an 11 point drop.
Mr.
1 thought it was worth 1 at the
beginning.
He still thinks it's worth 1.
That's no drop.
Mr. H equals 0 thought it was
worth .2 at the beginning and
still thinks it's worth .2.
That's no drop.
No matter who you pick,
I think the worst one is .5,
.5 thought it was worth--we
have to figure it out,
25 percent chance of going down
here,
75 up there.
So .75 .5 is .8, right?
25 percent of .2 is .05.
So Mr. H equals .5,
thinks the expected payoff is
.8,75 percent of one of those
1s, and 25 percent of .2 is
another .05.
So .75 and .05 is .8.
So he thinks down here where
he's a .5 it's now worth .5 and
.5 of this.
It's .6.
So he thought the drop would be
from 80 to 60,
a 20 point drop.
That's the biggest drop anybody
could imagine,
20 points.
Most people are at 11 points or
0 points or something like that.
Nobody's at a 26 point drop.
That's way bigger than anybody
could imagine is justified by
the bad news in the economy,
yet that's what the equilibrium
becomes,
from 95 percent to 69 percent.
So why is that?
And that's the end of the story.
What happened in the drop?
Well, three things went wrong.
The first thing is that 87 is
the marginal buyer,
so everyone above him bought.
All these optimists were buying.
Everyone else sold and lent
money.
Student: You just assume
that, right.
Prof: What?
Student: You just said
let's assume 87 is the marginal
buyer?
Prof: I'm assuming that
and it's going to turn out to be
the correct answer.
Now, how did I know 87?
Well, you'll see at the end.
Yeah, question?
No.
Just fixing your hair,
that's okay.
So Mr. 87 is the marginal buyer.
So those guys at the top bought.
Now, how could they afford to
buy so much?
Well, they're borrowing so much.
They're borrowing .69 plus they
already had their .31
[correction: their .13],
so together they can spend .69
.13.
That's .82 that they're
spending and they're only buying
87, and so 82 over 87 is about
95.
So there's a little rounding
going on.
So that's why the price is .95.
Now, why did it crash to .69?
It crashed because look what
happened.
These total optimists at the
beginning, the top 13 percent,
they spent all the money that
they had, their 13 percent gold,
they spent the 13 percent.
They borrowed everything they
could to the hilt so they owed
.69 in both states.
So what happens to them here?
They spent all their gold and
they owe the total value of
their collateral.
They're wiped out here.
They've got nothing left.
So the most optimistic people
in the economy,
they're just out of the
economy.
They've all gone bankrupt.
So now we've got a smaller
population with less optimistic
people, and so these new
optimists are going to do the
buying now.
Well, first of all they don't
think the asset's worth as much
for a bunch of reasons.
One is they got bad news,
so the people who are left
don't think it's worth as much
as they did from the beginning.
Plus the most optimistic people
at the beginning aren't there
either,
and then lastly and most
importantly the people who are
left can't borrow very much
money because the leverage at
the beginning was .95 over .26,
you could borrow 69,
so you had to pay down .26.
That's 3.6 leverage.
Here the price is .69.
You can only borrow .2,
so you have to put .49 down.
The leverage is 1.4.
So you went from 3 and 1 half
leverage to 1 and 1 half
leverage.
The leverage collapsed,
and so these guys who are left
they are not as optimistic
themselves because they've got
bad news,
the most optimistic people are
gone,
and the people who want to do
the buying can't borrow as much.
So there are three reasons that
drives the price down.
The marginal buyer becomes a
much lower guy than before,
and so that's why the price is
lower.
It's not just the bad news
because Mr.
87 would never have justified
that drop.
It's because the thing has
fallen into more pessimistic
hands.
So all those bankers and hedge
funds who bought all those
mortgage securities at the
beginning, they've been wiped
out by now.
They're way up here.
They can't buy.
They're much more sober people
who are left who also know we've
had bad news.
They're willing to pay less to
begin with, and they are more
pessimistic, and they can't
borrow very much,
so the price drops for all
those reasons.
I think that's the essence of
the crash.
Three reasons,
the people going bankrupt who
are the most optimistic buyers,
the second reason because the
news was bad.
That's the first reason.
The news was bad,
optimistic buyers going out and
the leverage collapsing,
so the price drops a long way.
So I'll end with one more slide
and then sum up.
The last slide is his question
about the classes of people.
It's a little different now
than it was before.
There are different classes of
people.
So let's just think about this.
Why was the marginal buyer Mr.
87?
I mean, after all we just
computed, Mr.
87 thinks the value of the
asset's 98, not 95.
Mr.
86 also thinks the value of the
asset is 98 about,
so why didn't 86 buy?
He was getting a good deal at
the beginning.
Why wasn't 86 buying when he
thinks it's worth 98 here?
Mr.
.86, remember,
is not supposed to buy.
He's going to buy the next time.
See Mr.
86 there, he's the cautious
optimist.
Mr.
86 there, just below 87,
he's going to buy after the
crash, but he's not buying now.
So why is it that he's not
buying at the beginning?
Well, so this is the only
subtlety, but it's the answer to
your question.
Mr.
86 says to himself,
"I can make a profit.
I think it's worth 98 and I
only have to pay 95.
That's like a 3 percent
expected return and I'm risk
neutral so that's great.
If I'm right it goes from 95 to
100.
I can get 5 percent.
On the other hand,
maybe I should wait for the
crash.
If the crash comes I only have
to pay 69.
I can get 40 percent return,
31 over 69, whatever that is.
I can get a 40 percent return
if there's a crash.
That's much better than my 5
percent if I'm right."
So that guy is waiting to make
money in the cash.
So of course by waiting and
buying in the crash he's helping
to reduce the terrible calamity,
because he's a buyer.
If we just had more people like
that--I think of that as Warren
Buffett, I called him the
cautious optimist,
all the way down to Mr.
.74.
Mr.
.75, for example,
also thinks the asset is worth
more than .95 at the beginning,
but he doesn't buy either,
so all these people,
the cautious optimists,
they're holding out for the
crash and the crash would be
much worse without them,
but they don't eliminate the
crash because there are not
enough of them.
So here are the three classes
of people you were thinking
about.
They're not quite as optimistic.
They still think it's a good
buy, but they decide not to buy
waiting for the crash.
Now, how did I know that it
would stop at 87 and 74?
How did I get all those numbers?
Well, I don't have time to
derive them, those are the
equations, but I can explain it
very simply.
You see, thinking you're going
to take advantage of the crash
means you must have a high H.
You think if things go here
they're still going to end up
okay.
That's why you think there's a
big profit opportunity.
But if your H is too high you
don't think you're ever going to
get to the crash.
So you've only got this small
intermediate group of people,
the Warren Buffett like people,
who are optimistic enough to
think that we're going to pull
out of our depression,
pull out of the crash and still
there's a profit opportunity,
and yet think that the crash is
likely enough so that they'll
wait for it.
People who think they'll make a
bigger profit,
higher H once the crash starts,
well, they don't even think the
crash is going to happen.
So I've made a big assumption
that the people with high Hs
always have high Hs,
but I think that's life.
I think that's not a bad
assumption.
Every hedge fund guy I've ever
talked to who thought that this
was a low probability event also
thought we were going to come
out of it and things wouldn't be
that bad.
So I'm not saying that these
people don't learn.
Everybody learns.
When they see the first piece
of bad news they're more
pessimistic.
You go from 1.69 percent to 13
percent.
So it's not like people aren't
learning.
They are learning,
but relative to the rest of the
population if you started
optimistic you stay optimistic,
and that's why there's only a
small group of Warren Buffetts
who can save the situation.
So that's my model of the
leverage cycle,
of what happens.
Three bad things happen,
bad news, can't do anything
about that, the leveraged buyers
get crushed, go out of business
and leverage collapses.
And when the prices are really
low the whole economy is
suffering tremendously and
innocent people who had nothing
to do with all these markets,
the price of everything,
every asset is low so they
can't borrow.
They can't get loans.
Margins are so tough.
They're small businesses.
They can't borrow.
They're totally crushed down
here, so how would we save the
economy?
We'd undo the three things that
happened.
We can't undo the bad news,
but the three things that
happened were uncertainty went
up.
It wasn't just bad news,
it was scary bad news.
So this gap between 1 and .2 is
much bigger than that gap.
That's why the leverage went
down.
Volatility went up.
So you have to contain the bad
news.
That would help.
You have to contain the bad
news, that's A.
So you can't eliminate the bad
news, but you can contain the
volatility of the bad news.
Secondly you have to increase
the leverage,
and thirdly you have to make up
for the people who've gotten
destroyed.
The buying power is gone.
Somehow the government has to
replace that temporarily.
So those are the three things
we should be doing now,
and in the long run we should
never have let leverage get so
high up here.
That's what made the price so
high up here,
and that's why everyone got
wiped out down here because they
were borrowing so much.
We should never have let that
happen.
So if we regulate the economy
not to let leverage get so high
we won't have such a crash,
but if we do have a crash the
way to deal with it is to undo
the three things that went
wrong.
That's the sort of story that
I've been telling.
Yes?
Student: Do you have a
theory for what the right amount
of leverage is?
Prof: That's a wonderful
question, and of course I've
been asked that before.
So let me put it in several
different ways.
Let's take the most
hypercritical way.
I presented this theory,
remember, starting in 2000,
so way before the crash.
And so people would say then,
"Oh,
very nice, very cute,
but first all there's not going
to be a crash and secondly how
could we ever know what the
right amount of leverage is.
It's an impossible pie in the
sky goal to regulate leverage.
Well, you see,
that's why--I say it's
difficult, I agree,
but we've already faced this
problem.
We regulate the interest rate.
How does the Fed know that the
interest rate's too low or too
high?
What the Fed does is it
monitors a bunch of stuff and
realizes the economy is
overheated.
Things are changing.
Suddenly output is going way up
and inflation is starting to go
up.
Then the Fed raises the
interest rate,
or maybe people are being
thrown out of work then the Fed
lowers the interest rate.
So something changes in the
economy.
They don't know so precisely
what to do,
but something's changed that
gives them a clue about which
way to move interest rates,
and over the course of 80
years, I guess since the
Depression,
since it was created,
over 70 or 80 years since then
they've gotten better and better
at regulating the interest.
So I put this picture up for a
reason last class.
You remember the picture,
which I'm going to get to now,
of the history of leverage.
So here's the history of
leverage, the purple,
in the housing market.
And then the blue is the
history of leverage,
it's the loan to value,
basically.
I put money down starting from
the top and going down.
So from the bottom it's loan to
value.
So I've got the history of loan
to value in the securities
market and in the mortgage
market.
Now, I think that the Fed
should be monitoring this,
and not only should be
monitoring it,
should be making it as public
as the interest rates are.
So how come I had to present
Ellington's data on observations
it made in the market,
because Ellington seems to have
been the only company in the
county that kept this data.
Nobody else seemed to recognize
how important it was,
and we kept it.
So the Fed doesn't have these
numbers going back.
If it did it would have seen
that leverage had suddenly
jumped up here and that leverage
was much higher than it was
before,
and it would see if it
monitored leverage in the
housing market that leverage was
skyrocketing.
Of course everybody knew this,
they just didn't think it was
an important thing to pay
attention to,
but if they were paying
attention to it and keeping
these numbers,
we had to do this at Ellington
by going house by house through
every house looking at what the
leverage was and taking the
average,
if they had done that,
I mean they could have done
that easily,
and if they did do that,
and if they were publishing it,
and every economist was aware
of it I think things would have
been very different.
They would have said we ought
to tighten leverage.
Exactly how much should we
tighten it?
Well, they would have said,
"I don't know exactly,
but we would have forced banks
not to allow loans with 3
percent down."
Should it be 10 percent,
or 15 percent,
or 8 percent?
It's a little hard to say what
exactly the right number is,
but we would have picked a
number higher than 3 percent and
we would have avoided a huge
problem,
and in later years we'll get
better and better at picking
that number.
So I'm trying to answer your
question.
So in the securities market
another thing you could do,
another trick you could do is
you could say we'll pass a rule
that says you can't--
here leverage is going down,
right?
They're asking for more and
more margins.
You could pass a rule that says
you can't double your margins
from 10 percent to 20 percent or
20 to 40.
You can't double them in under
four months, say,
on average across some security
class.
You can't double them in less
than four months or less than
six months.
So that would have kept
leverage from collapsing so
fast,
and then lenders knowing that
when the crisis was starting,
you know, they're making one
day loans.
See, they always think.
"Well, it's a one day loan
and things start to look dicey
I'll just demand a huge amount
of leverage the next day.
I'll get my money back tomorrow
and then the day after tomorrow
I'm not going to make the same
loan.
I'll ask for a lot more
margin."
So I'm saying,
suppose you tell them in
advance you have to keep making
the same loan and you can't
double the margin?
You can increase it but you
have to take at least six months
to double it.
Well, they'll know in advance
that they're not going to be
able to react very quickly to
problems,
and so in advance they'll ask
for more margin down so they
won't have to double to get to a
safe level when something starts
happening because they'll
already be safer.
So that's a way of not having
to actually know what the right
number is by just slowing down
their response and relying on
them to anticipate how bad
things might be and they're
already starting to respond at
the beginning.
So I'm not saying I've got
exactly the right formula,
but you see I think if you
think about it and start to work
on this,
and most importantly you make
these numbers public,
you're going to change the way
everybody,
you know, rules will develop.
Yeah?
Student: To sort of
connect to that,
so are they going to set like
one leverage rate or is it going
to be like for each class?
Prof: Yes,
each class of security will
have a different leverage.
Student: When you say
class of security like do you
mean like different...
Prof: Well,
the government already makes a
lot of loans through Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac,
but Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
will have to ask for at least 20
percent down.
Prime securities,
prime mortgages will have to
have at least this much amount
of money down.
So, on the housing market
you'll have to have a certain
amount of money down.
On Treasuries you can have a
very high leverage.
On mortgages,
plain simple mortgages,
you can have not quite as high
a leverage, but a pretty high
leverage.
On mortgage derivatives,
which are much more
complicated, the leverage has to
be much less.
So you might say there'll be
some rule that says--
so anyway those are the kinds
of classes that I have in mind,
and we have to work out exactly
how they're going to be
regulated.
So it's a little bit
complicated.
So let me answer your question
in two parts.
Yes, it has to depend on the
kind of security,
and b) even trying to answer
your question I'm revealing that
it's not so obvious exactly what
the formula is and how to do it,
but this has to be worked out.
Yep?
Student: Is this some
kind of like Phillips curve
relationship here that you could
make between the amount of
leverage and unemployment that
kind of it's all the same like
Phillips curve like other
occasions that end up being
awful also or is it...
Prof: Yes, yes.
I think that's the whole point
of the crisis that the things
feedback on each other.
The feedback is the most
important thing.
So in the crisis let's take any
one of these.
When leverage starts to go down
that makes the prices start to
go down,
but when the prices start to go
down people get more worried
that things are going to go down
further,
I mean, they have good reason
to worry,
and so the leverage goes down
more which makes the prices go
down more,
and so they feed back on each
other.
So definitely it's a spiral of
one thing affecting the other.
And of course,
the more the prices are going
down the more the optimists are
losing money and your best
buyers are getting wiped out,
and that's a third thing.
Those three things are always
feeding back on each other.
Student: Is there a
Lucas like critique,
though, of saying that people
should be able to expect this
coming forward and they should
account for that?
Prof: No,
because the model was totally
rational.
Every person did expect all
this.
Everyone anticipated perfectly
what would happen.
So Lucas critique is people
should realize the environment
they're in,
but here in this environment
everybody up here understood
from the very beginning that the
prices were going to go down to
.69.
They realized that there was
going to be this acceleration of
problems,
and so they all anticipated it,
but still they wanted to buy
because they didn't think they
were going to get down there.
They thought they were going to
go up here.
So remember,
I don't know if I have it in
this slide, but one of my most
amazing pictures was this one of
what happened to the market.
Open.
So what happened to the market
here, which I think I showed you
last time, I mean,
I know I did,
but I'll just show it to you
again.
Now with this new perspective
you can look at it.
Presents, so this is Jerusalem,
I gave this talk in Jerusalem.
Second talk,
so you remember this picture?
I hope it was in this slide.
Yes, it was here.
Here.
Remember what happened in the
world?
It was shocking how bad and how
fast it was.
So in 2007, beginning of 2007,
right, we're not far from the
beginning of 2007.
That's three years ago people
were expecting 40 percent losses
for these lower tranches.
So how could you get such an
astronomical loss?
What was happening?
They were already anticipating
this spiral.
If you looked at just what
housing prices were there,
and you say 30 percent guys
being thrown out,
and housing prices are down 4
percent,
that's hardly any loss at all,
because if you get 96 percent
back on the house and you have a
few expenses and only 30 percent
are defaulting,
there was hardly anybody
defaulting.
Remember that curve we showed
where there weren't almost any
losses and no one going
delinquent yet?
They already anticipated that
there were going to be lots of
people thrown out of their
houses and when they got thrown
out of their houses the housing
prices were going to collapse.
So this market was collapsing
already because people were
anticipating a lot of the
feedbacks and stuff that were
going to happen later.
They didn't just extrapolate
the number of defaults,
they also had to extrapolate
the housing prices and stuff
going down.
And so in this model everybody
is doing that complicated
extrapolation and they're
figuring it all out,
but even so they still want to
put themselves in the cycle
because they still think they
have a profit opportunity.
They can't stop themselves from
investing.
That's why you need regulation.
It's like a prisoner's dilemma.
Everybody knows what the danger
is,
they still want to do it and
the only way to stop them from
doing it,
you can't lecture them about
irrational exuberance,
they know what's going to
happen and they still want to do
it.
They don't think that's going
to happen.
They know what could happen and
they still want to do it.
Now, I think in reality Shiller
is partly right.
I think that people didn't
really realize how bad it could
have gotten.
My own hedge fund lost money.
We didn't anticipate how bad it
was because so many things went
wrong.
We just underestimated all the
feedbacks.
So there is the spiral and
there were just more things
going wrong than we anticipated.
So I wouldn't stick 100 percent
to my story.
I think there's something to
what Shiller says,
but I wouldn't definitely stick
to 100 percent of his story of
it being all irrational
exuberance.
Any other questions?
Now that we have five minutes
left for--so I'm willing to keep
going.
So let's just pause.
Any more questions on this
story of the crisis or anything
else about the crisis you want
to ask, or...?
Yeah?
Student: How receptive
are the regulators to this idea?
Prof: Well,
that's a good question.
I talk to them now all the time
whereas I never did before.
So I'm meeting Dudley tomorrow.
He's the head of the New York
Fed.
So I go there quite frequently
like once a month now.
I'm on some panels.
There are other academics going
too.
So I didn't do that before,
so clearly they are paying
attention to it.
I think there are other people
saying that leverage is
important, Soros,
being a famous hedge fund
person who says it.
There are other people saying
that you should reduce
principal.
Remember, I said that the way
to solve the housing foreclosure
problem is reducing principal.
They're now holding hearings in
Congress.
I could have gone Tuesday to
testify, but I have already
testified, but they're having
other hearings now.
I didn't go because I was
teaching, but there were a lot
of people who went,
and a lot of people said we
should reduce principal.
And a year ago when I was
saying that hardly anyone else
was saying it,
although there were others,
but very few.
The people at my hedge fund,
we all pretty much see eye to
eye on this and some other hedge
funds were saying that.
But now, I think,
there's a growing consensus
that we have to reduce
principal.
What does that do?
It makes the loan smaller
relative to the value of the
house.
In other words,
it reduces the leverage of
homeowners.
So we have to get back to a
credible level of leverage.
So the bad news is that
although they're very receptive
and although they're listening
carefully and they keep inviting
me to speak I don't see much
signs that they're doing
anything.
And the one thing that they
should have done by now is
collected all this data.
So they should have gone to all
the big lenders and said,
the Fed should have,
and said, "This is the
margins we're charging on all
our different securities,
here they are,"
and then the Fed would be able
to monitor how much they were
going up and down.
Now, a bunch of these lenders
themselves have also become
excited about what I'm doing,
and they're starting to publish
reports about it.
So one, Credit Suisse,
for example,
their research department now
thinks that a better measure of
money is not just M1 and M2 and
all that stuff,
but how many leveraged loans
are made in the Repo market,
and they add that to the money
supply,
and they think that gives them
a much better picture of the
economy.
So it's all sort of based on
these ideas and I think I got
them interested in it,
or was one of the people that
got them interested in it.
But they aren't going to
publish their leverage numbers
unless everybody else does
because why should they give
away private information?
Why should they say,
"We're lending to
Ellington on slightly less
generous or more generous terms
than we're lending to some other
guy."
One of the two of us is going
to feel bad about it,
and so they're not going to do
that.
And so the government is the
only one that can get the
information out of them.
And the government shouldn't
say who are they lending to
person by person,
they should give the average
number.
This is the average margin
they're charging people,
the average number the banks in
general are charging people then
you won't be revealing any
private information,
giving away any secrets.
So that's the worst news that
they're not collecting the data
yet, and it's shocking to me.
So I'm going to yell at Dudley
about that again Friday,
but I've done it before,
so hopefully they're going to
do that.
They say they're going to do
that, so I believe they'll do
that.
And I believe that once they
have all these numbers they're
going to start to think
differently.
So there are all these
initiatives in Congress,
and in the Fed,
and in the Treasury to try and
monitor leverage and try to
regulate it,
but every time they get down to
actually doing something they
ask questions like you did,
what exactly should the rule
be, and they seem paralyzed by
not being able to figure out the
exact rule.
But I think that's an
unnecessary paralysis because we
don't have to have to the final
rule to start doing stuff.
Yes?
Student: I've got one
more question.
How and who do you think should
be doing this?
Prof: The Fed.
The Fed has the power to do it.
The Fed already regulates
margins on stocks,
right?
They set the margin at 50
percent or something,
and so they could change that
and they have changed that in
the past.
So the Fed has the authority to
do that.
The Fed did that after 9/11.
They called everybody up and
said, right after 9/11,
and said, "You cannot
change your margins,"
and nobody changed their
margins.
I mean if ever there was a day
when people were nervous and
wanted to have a higher margin
it was on 9/12.
Nobody changed their margins.
So they've done it before,
but that's a pretty extreme
day.